politicians and experts can tell you
whatever is the biggest challenge that
we're facing in America today but this
issue right here that I'm going to share
with you may be the biggest issue and
that's the southern border and why I
love data is because you can tell
stories you can sell you can try to
convince people but data cuts through
all the lies and the anybody
may tell us let me give you some data
here for you to look at the numbers so
couple different things I can literally
start anywhere here's one of them for
you ready first chart do you know this
is the first time in the history of
America where we have more illegal
immigrants coming to America than actual
Americans having kids this has never
happened before in the history of
America let me give you the next one
here for you border patrol data since
October of 1999 no single month
exceeding 225,000 migrant apprehensions
ever in the history of America the
previous record was May of 2022 December
of 2022 do you know when's the first
time we crossed 225,000 in a single
month it's called December and not the
entire month it's in the first 27 days
of the month in December that we had
225,000 let me give you some more data
here according to this chart here as of
right now we have roughly 8.5 million
encounters during Biden's Administration
it's on track to be 12,99 th000 under
his administration more than the
previous three terms combined and by the
way this isn't like he's following
Barack Obama's footsteps because Barack
Obama any any article you pull up about
Barack Obama ABC News Economist pull him
up he has the record for deporting the
most illegal immigrants ever in the
history of America there's a reason why
they call him the deporter and chief no
one's ever deported as many as Obama has
so Biden's not following his footsteps
here's another one for you as well you
ready with this chart charts don't lie
you see what this is see anything you
look at that becomes a hockey stick you
want to know what the hell is going on
total H1B Visa registration filings from
2004 to 2024 when you look at the
numbers Barack Obama he hit his numbers
what was the minimum 85,000 look at the
numbers all the way because of 2008 2009
he went to 163 85 85 85 look at what
Biden does
skyrocketing number of H1B Visa
applications what the hell is going on
in America today with immigration we're
going to talk about that
today
okay so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel let's get right into it so
why is why is this happening I mean I I
showed you so many numbers I'll show you
a couple more here this is again another
one look at the chart skyrocketing right
here's another one total apprehensions
look at this number this just doesn't
make any sense how do you go from small
numbers to 1.66 2.21 2 million5 and then
even this one here look at this boom
boom boom boom boom boom every month
back to back to back to back to back so
they'll say well you know this has to do
with title 42 because May of 2023 Trump
had this title 42 which he used as a
Public Health crisis saying no if you're
here we have to send you back and it
expired May of 2023 but this is not a
problem that we've been having just
since May of 20123 this is a problem
we've been having since you've been in
office and by the way a person can act
hard you know what I mean by act hard
you know somebody's like wa you I see
him let me tell you what we're going to
do to him and we're telling you this is
not an open border don't come over here
when the camera's on and he was like no
no okay I no go ahead no no go ahead go
ahead go inside you can talk as much
an act hard as you want 85 million
encounters on track to be 12,99 th000
under your watch one term by the way you
know why this is even scarier let me
read you three story you ready let's
tell a story for you reported by New
York Post on September 2nd Venezuelan
immigrant Daniel Hernandez Martinez who
crossed the Southwest border illegally
in July had been arrested six times on
14 different charges since arriving in
New York here's another one for you an
illegal immigrant from Peru was charged
with murder an Eagle Pass Texas on
September 19 he had initially crossed
illegally into Eagle Pass in May and was
released into the US with a 2025 court
date can you imagine you come through
hey man this guy's going to do something
don't worry about it let's have a court
date in 2025 go hang out and enjoy the
country sightseeing a little bit we'll
see you in two years it's going to be
okay we'll see you in a year it's going
to be okay on September 6th border
Patrol agents patrolling near Fronton
Texas discovered backpacks with ammo and
a homemade explosive in the same area
where cartel gunmen had been repeatedly
seen on cameras Crossing illegally into
the US I can't tell you hundreds of
stories like this this is what's
happening if you live not by the border
you're like why would I be worried about
this I don't care about this but they're
going all over the place FYI why should
this be a concern let me give you some
more data here 169 individuals on the
terrorist watch list apprehended in 2023
huh
169 18 individuals on the terrorist
watch list apprehended in September
alone 1.7 million known Goa aways people
they didn't catch since 2021 if you're
wondering what that 1.7 can compare to
because again we want data let's compare
Biden final 3 years Trump's final three
years it's three times as much as
Trump's on his final three years just so
you know that's what's taking place on
top of that 35,43 3 aliens with criminal
convictions warrants arrested in 2023
598 known gang members arrested in 2023
including 178 MS13 members
27,29 3 pounds of fentanyl Seas at the
Southwest border in 2023 enough to kill
6 billion people enough to kill America
19 times those are the numbers we got
here today with it's not an issue though
why should we worry about this and then
a see you got to love this girl's
determination and driving how great she
sells it and how she uses a crisis to
respect her game watch what she says
here she says the problem with this we
have is yes we have this stuff going on
but we have a documentation problem I'll
let her say she's going to do a much
better job telling you what she thinks
we need to do with all these illegal
immigrants in America from all parts of
the political Spectrum one of the
biggest issues that we have when it
comes to immigration is the fact that we
have an undocumented population now you
can fix that by trying to build a wall
or you can fix that by trying to
document people and create a path to
citizenship way so you listen today
you're like okay what an interesting
strategy let it open the Border let him
come here 65% of Hispanics are going to
vote Democratic why does the casino
always win because the house rules so
the house becomes what so let's just say
12 million let's just take a number you
make them legal of the 12 million let
just say your third vote 3 million vote
65% are going to vote Democrat so that's
a million 950,000 let's just say 2
million vote Democrat 1 million votes
Republican that's a net POS positive of
of what of a million votes to the
Democratic party could that be them
flipping Texas cuz they're targeting
Texas they've been trying to Target
Texas you know what happens if they flip
Texas they own America for a couple
decades literally they own America for a
couple decades you got to give them
credit for the strategy dark yes
deceptive absolutely effective 100% now
to all the people who are like wow
what's wrong with this border and why
are you guys Patrick look at what you
look like you don't look white you are
from Iran shame on you did you forget
how you got here you're an immigrant
America's about people like you we came
legally you think I can swim from Iran
to here not that good of a swimmer it's
a long ass swim right what do we do we
went to Germany refugee camp year and a
half waited applied for green card in '
84 didn't get it till 1990 then we came
to the states then I served into the US
Army then all the other stuff happened
this is not the same thing by the way
let me give you perspective here you
know which company in the world does the
most Topline Revenue it's a company that
does roughly $24 trillion of Revenue you
may say I've never heard I thought
Apple's the biggest company in the world
no this is the biggest company in the
world it has 24 trillion a year that
company is called United States of
America you know what Apple's valuation
is give or take2 and half to3 trillion
can you imagine you and I go to Apple
and walk into the building at any time
2:00 in the morning walk in does Apple
leave the doors open well no no they
would that's stupid why would anybody
iing do that that's a business America
is a big business it employs a lot of
people roughly 150 160 Mill no no you
can't compare those two together oh so
apple is doing the right thing to keep
the doors closed and have an ID to go in
before I walk into that place but no no
no no no not America we got to let it
open let me give you another data here
for you the logic makes no sense you
would never live your house that way
your home wherever you live leave the
door open let anybody come in would you
be okay with that how about you let
seven people live with you let five
people live with you let three people
live with you how many extra bedrooms
you got do you have an empty couch let
somebody sleep on that couch why are you
being so selfish how dare you be so
selfish why are you only caring about
yourself you are not American you should
let somebody sleep on that couch you
have three bathrooms in your house four
TVs you're rich you don't need all those
four TVs let somebody else go watch some
of those TVs in your house we got 12
million people coming here so if you're
watching this and you're saying I'm all
for this perfect if you're for this and
you're voting for this let us have three
people move in your house they need a
place Elon Musk said it best what did he
say he said hey if we go at this pace of
building homes the US construction
industry can increase available housing
by 1 to 2% per year US population is 330
million people out of 8 billion so if
just 4% of the Earth moves here housing
would need to double which is impossible
causing a massive homeless problem and
housing price to be astronomical
unaffordable by the way last but not
least you ready so these people that are
coming from the border are they software
Engineers I don't know what do you think
are they coders are they PhD doctors
that that license can be transfer to
America you know the answer is no most
of the time are they dentists are they
high paying jobs do you think if they
were high paying jobs they wouldn't be
okay where they're at except maybe if
they're living in a communistic type of
a Nation the point is they probably
don't have a certificate that's going to
translate to America to be a high paying
job which means they're going to have a
low paining job okay what do you think
AI is going to replace first high paying
job or low pain job so if AI replaces
low paying job first boom right now
there's software we plug this video in
it's going to give us a top 10 short
clips of this video it'll edit it for us
it'll put the captions on it it'll write
a description and we don't need any
editors to do that it replace two
editors jobs right now that software is
available for us AI right what is it
going to do you think it's going to
replace them no so what happens if all
these people that are coming here and
they don't have that technical job hard
skill to replace then what do we have to
do with them maybe Andrew Yang is right
that we have to pay them you bi income
being sent to them now they don't have a
job now crime goes up now in the next 2
3 4 terms maybe America becomes
Venezuela what do you think that would
never happen here the way we're going it
is this is not like a regular thing to
just be sitting around saying it's not a
big deal you guys are just
overexaggerating I just gave you data if
this data doesn't get you sitting there
saying what the hell are we doing maybe
you are okay with this thing turning
into Venezuela but if you're a Valu I
know for a fact you're like I'm not part
of that c I know you're not just telling
you we have some weird people that think
it's okay but data exposes all that BS
if you got value out of today's video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel if you like this video I got
another video I want you to watch called
Sanctuary City video if you've never
seen this oh my God you definitely must
watch this video take care everybody
bye-bye